the kids were just not into it at all
archie was a dinosaur for maybe five
minutes
no not even five not even five minutes
meghan markle is giving fans an inside
look at what her two kids with prince
harry are really like let's talk about
this for a second during a stop by the
ellen degeneres show the duchess of
sussex opens up about celebrating
halloween with two-year-old son archie
and five-month-old daughter lilibet we
wanted to do something fun for the kids
and then
the kids were just not into it at all
archie was a dinosaur for maybe five
minutes no no not even five not even
five minutes he put finally harry talked
him into putting the head on as for baby
lily her costume was literally so
stinking cute lily was a skunk she was a
little skunk it was so cute i know like
flower from bambi that's all right
he can call me a flower megan also sheds
more light on her kiddos telling ellen
about a sweet moment where archie
realized he was featured in his mom's
book the bench does archie know he's in
here does he know that's him and what
does he think of the book he does on
that first page that you open and you
see our dogs he goes that's pula that's
guy the picture book released ahead of
father's day in june details the special
bond between dad and son megan says she
was inspired by her two closest guys i
wrote this originally just as a poem for
my husband on father's day and it was
about my observation of him and you know
him being a dad which was the most
beautiful thing to watch and
and that was really the intention of it
and then once it was shared with a
couple of friends and and people that we
were close with they said no this
resonates for me too because it feels
really inclusive and there's
representation and it's just like a
sweet love story between a family but
before megan and harry were mom and dad
they were just two people trying to date
and live a normal life megan tells ellen
about a sweet moment early in her and
prince harry's romance and yes it
involves halloween he came to see me in
toronto and um
and our friends and his cousin eugenie
and now her husband jack they came as
well and the four of us snuck out in
halloween costumes to just have one fun
night on the town before it was out in
the world that we were a couple turns
out the couple was completely
unrecognizable it was a
post-apocalypse theme so we had all this
very bizarre costuming on and we were
able to just sort of have one final
fun night out since stepping back from
their royal duties in january 2020 megan
and harry have enjoyed both freedom and
privacy in their new life in montecito
california royal expert katie nicholl
tells et how the duke and duchess of
sussex have been settling into their new
community they're enjoying it they're
loving their new life and they also love
what it gives to archie
i think it's worth pointing out that
another of the reasons that they left
was so that archie could have a normal
ordinary childhood that he wasn't always
under the scrutiny of the media
spotlight and i think at their home they
have the space they are surrounded by
nature and they're left alone you know
there haven't been intrusive paparazzi
pictures of archie in the family because
they won't tolerate it they will take
action they've sent a very clear warning
out to the press for that and in doing
so they are giving archie this sort of
childhood that they want him to have one
away from the glare of the spotlight
[Music]
you